I was at the at the conference of Mike
money allotted one of the producer of
the real witch project and he's amazing
and he was talking about transmedia how
to get people involved and engage and he
used like only examples from Coney
Island which was amazing he builded
absolutely build a case and one of them
was you know he was talking about he was
doing about this hot dogs place which is
what was unable to place a famous place
Nathan sniffles okay so who's talking
about Nathan's Nathan's you know there
was a hot dog place and the hot dogs
with the thing there were three bags in
coney island that was in there maybe the
50s or the sixes and people kept going
and then Nathan's open just beside the
other place and hot dogs were a dollar
and a half but people kept going to the
three dollar place because they said you
know what if there I don't have they
can't be good so cheap the company so I
prefer to play three but you know be
sure they're going to be tacky so what
he was the guy there I mean the owner
did was to hire actors dressed them as
doctors and nurses and put them eating
hot dogs for a while so people said you
know there is a doctor eating there that
should be good and suddenly became the
most famous hotdog place in the world
and what he said you know the the the
lesson from this was foster discovery
let people discover things you know we
wanted we love to be first to discover
something we want to find a band that
somebody's going here's like I was the
guy that discovered that in the van and
now they're huge but you know I knew
them three years ago we love that so
it's stupid to ask people to talk about
you or to share a theme so too you know
Forrester discovery let them discover it
for themselves let them let them
discover it and then talk about it
because they you know somebody took them
about that and they're gonna be the next
guy talking about that thing then that's
important
you